The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Apparently.
We'll start slow.
So last time we were
talking, we just
started talking
about effective field
theory with a fine tuning.
And what actually
that means takes
a little bit of discussion.
So what you could
mean by a fine tuning
is that you have something
that's irrelevant.
You look at the operator,
you think it's irrelevant,
but it's not.
It's relevant.
Something that you should
include even at lowest order
in your power accounting.
But saying something
is irrelevant
means that you have a power
counting, that you understand
the power counting for the
theory, what the correct power
counting is.
So in this example
that I'll give,
what "irrelevant" will
mean is that you basically
do a dimensional
power counting, which
is how we usually
think of defining
irrelevant and relevant.
Do a dimensional power
counting and you end up
finding an operator that--
you find that the
operator looks irrelevant,
but when you do
calculations you can
see that should be relevant.
And that means,
really, what it means
is that this natural power
counting of dimensions
is not the right
one, and you have
to do something
more complicated.
But it is still is
a sense in which
it can be thought of as a fine
tuning, because as you'll see,
the changing of the power
counting from the naive one
to the more complicated
power counting
involves some kind of
tuning, if you like.
And it really, in
this case, we'll
see actually that
it corresponds not
to expanding around the trivial
fixed point, where you would
have a free theory,
but expanding
around an interactive
fixed point.
So it'll be a
little non-trivial,
but we'll be doing this
in the context of two
nucleon effective field theory.
And the advantage of this
is that the nucleons are
going to be non-relativistic.
So P is going to be
much less than M pi.
It's going to be a
very simple theory.
Everything that's an exchange
particle gets integrated out.
It's just a theory of
contact interactions,
and derivatives of
contact interactions.
And because it's
non-relativistic,
we can actually
calculate all the loops
to all orders and
perturbation theory,
and we'll do that in a minute.
So this theory, we can
calculate a lot of stuff.
And so we'll actually be able
to see how this non-trivial fine
tuning works, and explore
it from multiple directions,
and we'll be sure
that what we're saying
is actually correct.
So it can be a lesson
for understanding
some of the concepts and
other effective field theories
with the fine tuning, which
you might want to design,
where you don't have as
much ability to calculate.
All right, so let's
start off with something
simple, which is
elastic scattering.
And that's mostly what
we're going to talk about.
Two particles in,
two particles out.
Center of mass frame.
They scatter to some P's
coming in, P primes going out.
And this is basically a
problem that you could
treat with quantum mechanics.
It's like non-relativistic
scattering.
So if you have a
single partial wave,
then this scattering
is described
by a phase shift, delta.
And the relation of the
phase shift to the amplitude,
with our normalization for
the amplitude, is this.
So this is the S-matrix,
it's just a phase,
and that's the relation of
the S-matrix to the amplitude.
And this thing is the amplitude.
And I guess the
other thing we know
is that, by energy
conservation, the magnitude of P
is equal to the
magnitude of P prime.
All right, so if we
rearrange this equation,
and we write it as A and
put the phase, solve for a.
Could do that.
So that gives that
equation, which we
can rearrange a little further.
Now, there's kind of a
conventional way of writing it,
which is that the
amplitude should
be given by 1 over something
that's P cotangent delta.
Scattering angle, or
that S-matrix angle,
and then minus this IP.
OK?
So the I of--
the I's just-- shows
up here in this part,
and that's the complex
part of the amplitude.
That's basically going to
be related to unitarity,
that that IP is there.
This S-matrix is
obviously unitary.
This digress is 1.
All right, so let me
tell you something
about non-relativistic
scattering,
which on the face of it,
looks kind of non-trivial.
So this thing, P
cotangent delta.
So here, I was doing
a single partial wave.
Yeah, OK, no, it's fine.
So what is this L?
This L is the partial
I am considering.
S wave, P wave.
So L is 0 for the S wave,
L is 1 for the P wave.
And the statement is that if you
have a short range potential,
and you pick a wave, then
this P cotangent delta
with the appropriate power
of P can be a Taylor series
expansion of P. OK?
And this is actually
something that's
quite difficult to prove
in quantum mechanics,
this particular fact.
And it's called the
effective range expansion.
It's difficult to prove because
when you do quantum mechanics,
you pick a potential.
And I'm saying that this
is true for any potential.
So if you start doing quantum
mechanics with some potential,
you've got to prove that
you can put it in this form
irrespective of what the choice
of that potential would be.
And that makes it
a little bit tricky
to do in a quantum
mechanical setup.
But we'll see
actually that this is
very easy to prove from an
effective field theory setup.
So, as a way of getting
into this effective field
theory of two nucleons,
let's prove this fact.
So what is the Lagrangian
for this theory?
There's no-- it's
not a gauge theory,
so we just have
ordinary derivatives.
So if you like, you can think
of what I'm writing here
as kind of like our IV.D
term, except I think
the center of mass
frame, and this
would be like the
kinetic energy term,
but now it's just partial
squared with no D, et cetera.
And then there's a bunch
of contact interactions.
So there's a whole
bunch of operators
that are involved in
nucleon and fields
with some Wilson coefficients.
The notation here
is this S is kind
of a pseudonym for the channel.
So this S here--
maybe it should be a
script S or something,
is telling me what
channel I'm in,
and if in a
spectroscopic notation,
you'd say you're in the
2S plus 1 LJ channel.
So this would be the
angular momentum,
total momentum in the spin.
And these operators
here, for our purposes,
are four nuclear fields
with 2M derivatives.
Now, this is not really
the complete theory
for a couple of reasons.
Well, there's higher order
relativistic corrections
indicated by the dots.
There would also
be dots over here
That could have to do with
having more nucleon fields.
For example, I could have--
instead of just four,
I could have six.
But I don't need to worry
about those operators
for two-to-two scattering,
so I'm leaving them out.
So this is actually
the complete theory,
if we include these dots here,
for two-to-two scattering.
And this nucleon field,
[? its ?] spin [? at ?] half,
and it's isospin
been at half too,
so it includes both the
proton and the neutron.
Nucleons are fermions, and that
implies, actually, a relation,
because the wave function
has to be anti-symmetric.
And so actually, you know
that you can associate isospin
and the angular momentum
in the following
way because of this fact.
So all the isotriplets have
-1 to the S plus L even,
and the isosinglets have
-1 to the S plus L odd.
So that cuts down
by a factor of two
the number of combinations
you have to consider.
And basically, what
this theory has
is for some given channel
in and some given channel
out, which I could denote
in general different,
we get operators that
just will have some power
of the center of mass momentum.
P to the 2M.
And actually, just by angular
momentum conservation,
that has to be the same as that.
And so all that can
change is the L's.
And so if S is 0,
S is either 0 or 1,
because we have 2
spin half particles.
If S is zero, L will
be equal to L prime
because J is equal to
J prime, and there's
no shift of the spin.
So that's one possibility,
and if S is 1, then--
so S here is the
same, if S is 1,
then you can have L minus L
prime which is 2, so, or 0.
OK?
You're shifting by
one unit, and you
can compensate either by
having minus L prime be 0 or 2.
OK, so we conserve J.
So we can enumerate
all the possible partial waves.
We'll mostly focus
on the S wave.
So, let me write out some
of these operators for you.
So the first operator
has no derivatives,
and I can write it in a way that
makes the partial wave explicit
if I do the following.
And then there would be
some derivative operator.
And I'm going to pick
the normalization
to make our lives
as easy as possible,
as we usually do when we're
setting up the operator basis.
There's the first two guys
where this derivative operator
is like, [? grad squared ?]
to the left.
[? Grad ?] left dot
[? grad ?] right.
That [? grad ?] go to the right.
And these P's, if
you look at them,
they're just matrices in
the spin and isospin space.
So the two we're focusing
on are the S waves.
And in the S wave you
either have 1S0 or 3S1.
And so we've encoded
all the, sort of,
complexity in just these
matrices, which kind of just
go along for the ride, and
I'll tell you what they are.
So I sigma 2 projects you onto
a spin singlet, and I tau 2 tau
I projects you
onto an isotriplet.
And then likewise, 3S1,
which is a spin triplet,
you put I sigma 2
sigma I. I tau 2.
I tau 2 and I sigma 2 are
just because of the way
I wrote the operator.
I wrote it, instead
of writing N dagger N,
I wrote N transpose
N, all dagger.
And that means,
basically, you should
think about the way
this operator works,
is it annihilates two nucleons
in a particular spin wave,
or a particular spin,
isospin channel,
and then creates them again.
So annihilate, create.
So I just put the
two fields that
are doing the
annihilating together,
and the two fields that are
doing the creating together.
And that's nice because
you're annihilating them
in a particular channel.
So with those conventions,
our Feynman Rules
are particularly simple.
If we just have a
C0 in some channel,
then the Feynman Rule
is just minus IC0,
and if we have one of
these higher C2 operators
in the center of mass frame,
it's just minus IC2P squared.
In the center of
mass frame, that's
the center of mass momentum.
And remember, in the
center of mass frame,
P squared was equal
to P prime squared.
And so we can actually just
write down the Feynman Rule
for the complete
set of operators
there if we adopt
this convention.
So if you insert a guy
with 2M derivatives--
derivatives always
have to come in pairs
because of angular momentum.
You just have that
Feynman Rule, sum's
over the number of derivatives.
So this is the complete,
in this theory,
this is the complete
tree-level amplitude
from those interactions
over there.
It's very nice theory.
Simple.
What about loops?
We are going to need some loops.
So let's look at
the following loop,
and I'll start by looking
at just E equals 0.
Let's just take it,
take the nuclear arms
and then scatter them again.
So, in terms of
the momentum flow
I have some Q going
this way, and then I
have minus Q going that
way, that's my loop momenta.
So I get 2 coupling C0.
Want these to be 0's.
Ergo, DDQ.
And if I just kept the HQET
type term in my kinetic term,
then it would look
like that, OK?
So this is just--
for the moment, if we
just keep partial DT
in the kinetic term, which is
what we were doing in HQET,
then we would get that.
And that's a bad integral.
It's got a pinch singularity.
It's an ill-defined interval.
So just from that
little algebra,
we see that actually
keeping just the partial D
by DT in the kinetic term
is not the right thing
to do for this theory.
And that's because the kinetic
energy is a relevant operator
in quantum mechanics.
Whenever you write down
the Schrodinger equation,
you kept it.
So the right power
counting and should
have E, which is of
order P squared over 2M.
So the partial T term and the
[? grad ?] scored over M term
should be the same size.
So this is generically true
of two heavy particles.
They have a different power
counting for the kinetic term,
than HQET.
Any two heavy particles,
whether it's too heavy
quarks, two heavy nucleons,
two heavy anything.
All right, P should be
[? order ?] P squared over 2M.
AUDIENCE: E being
the kinetic energy?
PROFESSOR: So really,
what I mean here
is just the partial
T term in the action
over there should be the same
size as the [? grad ?] squared
over 2M.
Yes, I have pulled out the mass.
Yeah.
So just like in HQET,
to get this partial T
we pulled out the
mass, and we have
a kind of non-relativistic
type expansion.
And the difference here is
that we need the partial T
to be of
[? order grad squared ?]
over 2M, and that leads to
effectively counting velocities
rather than--
because you have to count
energies different than P's.
We won't spend too
long talking about
that because we have other
things to discuss here,
but this is a whole
interesting subject in itself.
The power counting
and what it means.
One thing that's kind of
interesting here which
we won't cover, which I
can't help but mention,
is that say you did quarks,
which was a gauge theory.
This is not a gauge theory
that we're talking about,
but let's-- but you could do a
gauge theory that has this type
of power counting and it has
exactly the same problem.
Just replace these heavy
nucleons by quarks,
and replace this dot here
by cooling potential.
Exactly the same problem
if you try to use HQET.
And in that theory,
too, you need
E to be of order
P squared over 2,
and that's called
non-relativistic QCD.
Or you could do heavy
electrons, where you
have QED as the gauge theory.
Non-relativistic
QED, same issue.
E has to be of order P squared
over M. And in gauge theory,
there's even a further
complication, which
is basically that there's
gauge particles that
want to talk to E, and
there's gauge particles that
want to talk to P, and
those are different sizes.
So you have something
called ultra-soft photons
and soft photons that are
the gauge particles for E,
and the gauge particles for P.
Kind of an interesting theory.
We want to have time
to talk about it.
Somebody wants to talk
about it for their project,
it's kind of fun.
OK, so we have to keep
P squared over 2M.
At least knowing a
little quantum mechanics,
we know that that's true.
Or running into this
pinch singularity,
we see that trying to do
something different than that
leads to problems.
So let's redo our calculation
here, but now keeping
that term, and see what we get.
Same bubble diagram.
Let me send in on each
of these legs E over 2,
so E is the total energy
that I'm sending in.
Convenient normalization.
Let's see how having the kinetic
energy fixes this pinch pole.
OK, so if you look at the
poles in the complex plane
here, what's happened is
you've split them like this.
So that you've moved
them along the real axis.
And so now you can just
think of a contour,
for example, if you want to
think in the complex Q0 plane,
you can think of doing a
contour integral like that.
Everything is well defined,
convergence at infinity,
everybody's happy.
So we can close
above, pick the polar.
Q0 is E over 2, minus Q
squared over 2M, plus I0.
Plug it back into the other one.
My notation is that N is
going to be D minus 1.
So when I do one of the
integrals by contour,
I go down a dimension.
I'll call that N.
So it's N here.
This integral we can do.
You have to be careful
about the epsilons.
Because they tell us tell
us whether it's minus IP
or plus IP.
ME is set up in my convention.
ME is P squared.
So this is giving a P, but
it's giving either a minus
IP or a plus IP, depending
on the sign of the I0,
but I know it's a minus IP.
So I used dimreg here.
Because if you look
at this integral,
there's three pairs of Q
upstairs, two downstairs.
So it's power law divergent.
But we don't see power
law divergences in dimreg,
we just get this finite answer.
And actually, that finite answer
is exactly the imaginary part
that you need if you
want to cut to graph,
and say that the cut of
the forward scattering
is the same as this
amplitude squared.
So it's exactly,
in essence, this
is the piece that you need
to be there by unitary.
If you were trying
to keep the E,
you could think,
well, maybe if I just
kept the E in this
calculation, it
would solve this pinch problem.
But it doesn't really do
it because if you really
stick with the partial D by DT
as your leading order action,
then the equations of
motion are equal 0, so.
You have to take equal
0 to go on [INAUDIBLE]..
So you can't really
avoid the pinch that way,
you really have to
take this kinetic term.
you have to take the kinetic
term to have both the partial
DT and the [? grad ?]
[? squared ?] over 2M.
OK, any questions so far?
All right, well
there's something here
that might bother you.
We've got an M upstairs.
M is big.
M is the mass the nucleon,
and it's appearing upstairs.
That's always a bad sign.
Usually a bad sign.
Well, at least that's something
we should worry about.
So let's figure out
where all the M's are.
Let's count all the
M's in the theory,
holding the momentum fixed.
So if we hold the
momentum fixed,
then [? grad ?] has no M's.
But partial T scales
like 1 over M.
And correspondingly,
T scales like M. OK.
X and [? grad ?] don't scale
but partial T and T do.
And that's exactly what makes
these two terms the same size.
So we can ask, what is the
scaling of our nucleon field?
And if we want to do that,
we go back to our action
and we just say the action
shouldn't have any scaling.
T has a scaling, so
there's an M in here.
This guy here, the whole
thing scales nicely, 1 over M.
From what we just
said over there.
This M cancels that
1 over M, so this guy
is therefore M to the 0.
The nucleon field has
no scaling with them.
So then, once you've done the
kinetic term to figure out
the scaling of the
nucleon field, you can do,
then, any other interaction.
So that the power
counting, the kinetic term,
is always which determines the
power counting of the field.
That's true in any theory,
any effective theory,
because you're--
that's the basis of
the fluctuations you're
describing by that field.
And once you've fixed
that counting, you've
got all the counting
you need, and now you
can go count other operators
like the one with 2M
derivatives.
And this guy here just has--
you can have just vector
derivatives, no time
derivatives, just vector
derivatives, 2M of them,
and nucleon fields.
So there's no M's in
there, that's M to the 0.
And this guy here is
an M. So this guy here
is C2M, must be a 1 over M. So
therefore, any C2M scales like
1 over M. And now
you see it's not
such a problem, because
here I have 2 C0's,
each one of them
scales like 1 over M,
I pick up one more
M in the numerator,
and that just makes the whole
thing feel like one over M.
Which is the same order that
the tree level was scaling,
the tree level with
scaling like 1 over M.
So loop diagrams and the tree
level both scale like 1 over M,
and that's actually
generically true
because every time I add
a loop I add a coupling,
and so those two M's can
compensate each other.
So there's no issue with M's.
So the one that graph is
the same size as tree level,
and they both go like
1 over M. If you now
do dimension counting, you can
say given that we've identified
that the C has an
M in it, if you
ask about the dimensions
of C, -2 minus 2M.
Because the dimensions of the
nucleon field are 3 halves.
And we're doing some expansion
in P much less than lambda,
so just by dimensional
power counting
we expect that the coefficients
would be of the following size.
We know that there's an M
and that it's the only M,
and all the rest
of the dimensions
you should think
of as being made up
by the stuff you
integrated it out.
So it could be the
pion, for example,
setting the scale lambda.
So what you'd expect
for the C2M's is
that this is how big they are,
and that the derivatives are
then being suppressed
because of these lambdas
and you're expanding for
P much less than lambda.
OK.
Are we happy so far?
All right, and
we'll see when you
do matching calculations, this
M [? law's ?] always there.
And this is just a nice, elegant
way of figuring that out.
Because this is a
very simple argument.
All right.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
if I totally understand.
How do you know that C2M--
PROFESSOR: Goes like 1 over M?
AUDIENCE: Yeah--
PROFESSOR: So the kinetic term--
so at first you
know this, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so I see.
You're worried about
whether there could be
1 over M squared corrections?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
In principle, there could be
1 over M squared corrections
from relativistic corrections,
so that this would
be the leading order term.
Yeah.
Not worse than that.
If you looked at the P cubed,
P to the fourth over 8M
cubed term, that term would
have a higher power of M,
and you could
imagine that there's
some relativistic corrections
in the four nucleons as well.
Yeah.
So we'll work basically
here, at lowest order
in the relativistic
corrections so
that you could put in the
relativistic corrections,
as well.
All right.
So we're basically stopping
at that order, which
is equivalent to
quantum mechanics,
but we could go
further if we wanted to
in this effective theory.
So now, let's think about other
loop diagrams in the theory,
without relativistic
corrections,
just with these interactions.
And let's insert the 2N and
the 2M derivative operator
on these vertices.
You see all the loops look
like this, they're all bubbles.
And that's the
same reason in HQET
that you don't have any
diagrams that kind of-- you
don't have diagrams that look
like this, because these types
of diagrams involve
antiparticles
and we only have particles.
So that's the beauty of a
non-relativistic theory,
you don't have any
diagrams like that.
You just have
diagrams like this.
And so basically, the
whole theory is bubbles.
The theory of bubbles.
If you go through
this loop diagram,
you do the pole the same way.
It's exactly the
same two propagators.
Then you get the same Q
squared minus ME, minus I0.
And the only
difference is you get
powers of Q in the numerator.
And this, so this integral
is one of the ones
that shows up in here.
And this integral, you can
do the same kind of trick
that you used when we were
discussing field definitions,
where you basically take
the top and organize it
by adding and subtracting.
So add and subtract
any like that.
And now, you can think,
N and M are integers,
just expand this thing out.
Some number of these factors,
some number of these factors.
But any time you get one
or more of these factors,
it cancels the
denominator and then
you end up with
scaleless integrals.
So basically, that means you
can throw this piece away.
So higher order
derivatives actually just
lead to ME's, whether
they act inside or outside
on the nucleon fields,
they lead to P squared.
Yeah, sorry.
This M is a little
M, and this is
supposed to be a big
M. Oh, N. Oh yeah,
I am also using that too.
Sorry.
Yes.
This is an integer.
I should call it J or something.
And the other M is
3 minus 2 epsilon.
Yeah, it's dangerous.
All right.
But this means that basically,
the graphs in this theory
are very simple.
So if we actually now consider
the complete set of diagrams,
or we impose--
we put the full
amplitude in there
and we consider these bubbles.
Because of this fact
that I just told
you, which doesn't change
when you insert more bubbles,
the bubbles all decouple
from each other.
The contact interaction
is decoupling them
from each other.
So here's a complete
amplitude with K insertions
of the coupling,
and K minus 1 loops.
OK, so we just completed all
the loop diagrams the theory,
and it's giving us
something that we can sum,
its a geometric series.
So this is for K minus 1
loops, we can sum them up.
So if you like I should have
called this the K-th term.
And if I sum up, cancel the
I on each side, you get that.
Let me round it again.
Like this.
So dividing out the
numerator, rearranging
the four pi over M's little
bit, I can write it like that.
And then we can
identify this thing here
as P cotangent delta.
OK, so P cotangent delta,
from our effective theory,
we calculate it to
be the sum over this,
P2M, where now I've
conveniently defined it,
hatted coefficients, which
are the following things.
And that just
cancels the M that's
in the C2M's, so C2 hat
scales like M to the 0.
So that's just a--
is an obvious way of
reorganizing things given
the factors of 4 pi
over M that we knew
had to sit out front
of this S matrix
calculation of the amplitude.
So we can identify P
cotangent delta as something
that doesn't involve any M's,
and that actually is also
what we would expect for
non-relativistic scattering.
So then you can look
at different waves,
and you can look at this
formula, and you can--
doing two of them will
show you how it works.
So S wave is L equals 0.
So that's something we can do
a Taylor expansion in P in.
And this is what the
Taylor series looks like.
And this has exactly
the form that we wanted.
This is 1-- some
constant 1 over A,
which is the scattering length.
Some constant times
P squared, which
is called the effective range.
And we see that
expansion coming out,
and we never had to specify
what the potential was,
because the effective
theory was agnostic to what
the potential was.
That's the whole power
of effective theory,
that you don't need to know
what the particles were that you
were integrating out, they
just give you some values
for these coefficients.
And those values exactly
become the effective range
and scattering length
in this theory.
AUDIENCE: So this seems
very [INAUDIBLE] dependent.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we're
going to talk about that.
Yes.
Yeah, that will encompass
the second half of lecture.
So we'll come to
that momentarily.
Let me just do one more
way, just so you see.
L equals 1.
in the L equals 1 case,
there's no C0 hat,
you need the derivatives
to correspond to the wave.
And so in this case, you
look at PQ cotangent delta,
the denominator starts at C2.
And the reason why there
is this P to the 2L plus 1
is just so that you
get the extra P here,
which compensates
the P's downstairs,
and again this thing
has a Taylor series.
Same story as over there, we
can identify the scattering link
for the P wave as
the 1 over C2 hat.
So all the higher partial
ways work the same way.
And you just have P to
the 2 L plus 1 in front
of your cotangent delta.
OK.
Here you can see how this
generalizes [INAUDIBLE]..
So that proves this
non-relativistic quantum
mechanics theorem.
And we did it without having to
specify what the potential was,
because the potential is
encoded in BC's and effectively
that's like a basis
expansion of the potential.
But it's a fun one because
it's in delta functions
and derivatives of
delta functions.
So we're doing a
local effective field
theory, which is not
something you'd think
of ever using for a basis--
well, maybe you
would, but most people
wouldn't think of using basis of
derivatives of delta functions
for quantum mechanics.
OK.
Well, you'd hope we can do
a little more than quantum
mechanics, right?
So you can think, if
you like, in terms
of determining the values
of the C's, you can say,
well, experiment tells me the
values of the scattering length
are 0, and that's indeed true.
So this equation that
C0 hat is equal to A,
you could view this as
a matching equation.
Putting back the
M, you have that.
And then for C2 hat, we
have r0 over 2, a squared.
So pretend that
experiment gives r0.
And a, which they
do measure, and then
you know the value of
your Wilson coefficients
and you can start
using this theory.
Now, if you think about
the power counting, if a
and r0 are order 1
over lambda, that's
the natural thing you'd expect.
Then you reproduce
what we expect.
Whatever it was a minute ago.
2M plus one.
So if all the constants
are scaling like whatever
their dimensions
are, in this case
they're both dimension
minus 1 in momentum units,
then you would reproduce
exactly with this power counting
that we said.
OK, so everything would be nice.
But nature is not so nice.
Or nature threw us in
a different direction.
When we actually look at the
value of these constants,
the scattering length is large.
So C0 is large, from
this point of view.
Let me quote some
numbers for you.
So in the 1S0 channel,
which is the larger one,
this guy is 23 fermis.
And in the 3S1 channel, it's
5 fermis, and both of these
are actually large.
We know they're large,
look at the errors.
If you want to think
about momentum units,
you could take 1 over a.
And for this guy here, taking
1 over a is giving him, like,
if I did the calculation
right, minus 8.30 MeV.
Oh, sorry, no.
That's this guy.
And this guy here is
giving 1 over a, is 36 MeV.
So if you thought the
natural size was the pion,
then you'd say, well, these
constants should be 1 over pi--
that these numbers that
are in MeV should be in pi.
And 8 MeV is a much smaller
number than 138 MeV.
36 is also a smaller
number than 130 MeV.
So both of these
guys are not natural.
In particular, this one you
see it's very not natural.
So there's a fine
tuning going on.
Some kind of fine tuning
from the perspective--
from our dimensional
counting EFT point of view.
There's a fine tuning
that's making the a big.
And if you look at
the other guys, the r0
and the other guys,
they are exactly
of the size you'd expect.
So there's no fine tuning there.
The only fine tuning is in a.
And not the other ones.
Just by comparing two data.
OK, so how do we deal with that?
It looks like we set
up a defective theory.
It has seems like
a beautiful theory,
it could describe some things
about quantum mechanics,
but then we learned that
our power counting sucks.
So what we want is
actually a power counting
it's a little different.
Where AP is of order 1, or
even AP much greater than 1,
we'd like that to be allowed.
Where our 0P is
much less than 1.
We'd like to be able to take a
scattering length effectively
into account to all orders,
and that means basically
that we want to
treat C0 as relevant.
We don't want 8MeV to be
the limit of the lowered--
the thing that goes downstairs
when we're making a power
expansion, right?
We'd like something like
M pi to be downstairs.
If we want M pi
to be downstairs,
you got to treat
AP to all orders.
And then you're just limited
by M pi which is the r0 term.
And that means you've
got to promote C0
from being irrelevant,
scaling like 1 over M lambda,
to something that's relevant.
So this is actually
a problem that
occurred because we just
proceeded and started
calculating, and we used
effectively the MS bar scheme
in dimensional regularization.
We saw powers and
fractions, we did nothing.
So let's try another scheme.
It's a little more physical.
Called offshell
momentum subtraction.
So what is offshell
momentum subtraction?
It says take the amplitude,
and in this non-relativistic
theory, you take P to be
at some imaginary point
so that you avoid any cuts.
And you can define--
and whatever channel we're
in, in this new r scheme,
you can define the amplitude
of that particular point
to be the tree level result.
OK, so any loops, if you
take them at this point,
you should get back
that result. So this
is the analog of what you
do in a relativistic theory
where you would take P squared
to be minus mu squared.
In the non-relativistic
theory, it's
always P that's showing up,
which is the three vector P,
magnitude of the three vector.
So we should assign
some rule for that.
And it's just, we take
it to be I times mu.
So how does this
change our calculation?
So let's go back to
this one calculation.
So now there's going to be
some counterterm needed.
It's going to be a
finite counterterm.
Let's see what it does.
So the loop graph gave this IP,
that's what this graph gave.
And this has to be just such
that if I set P equal to I mu,
that I get 0.
So this has two plus mu.
So the counterterm is
giving mu r, C0 squared.
And that exactly makes this
amplitude vanish at that point,
and that's what you want because
the tree level graph of the C0
is already giving
the right condition.
OK?
Is that clear to everybody?
This is the correction
to that, to this.
The tree level graph in the
amplitude here gave minus IC0,
so we already got what we want.
When we go to our
loop, we just want
to make sure it
doesn't contribute,
and that forces us to
put the plus mu there.
And so what this mu is doing is
tracking the power divergence
that dimreg in MS
bar did not see.
There was an integral is power
law divergence and our cut
off, mu r, has appeared
in the numerator
and has tracked that divergence.
So we're doing a
standard thing here where
we split the coefficient
into the bare coefficient
and to our more renormalized
and countertrend piece.
And unlike MS bar in this
particular normalization
scheme, there's a
finite correction there.
And we have a renormalization
group equation.
And if you work out what
that is from the counterterm,
it turns out that only this
one loop, it's one loop exact.
Showing that is a little
more work than I've done,
but it turns out that the beta
function is one loop exact,
higher bubbles don't
give any contribution
to this beta function, and this
is the anomalous dimension.
So we could just calculate
all those bubbles,
and pose the same type of thing.
And I've given you the
reference that does that.
So there's a renormalization
group equation
in this scheme which we
didn't have in MS bar.
In MS bar it was
scale independent.
We also have a connection
to the MS bar scheme
because if mu r was 0,
that corresponds to what
the MS bar result, right?
So C0 of 0 is where you can
think of putting your boundary
condition, which is matching to
the experiment, which is the a.
And the advantage of
this offshell subtraction
is that we have a mu, and
we can go somewhere else.
And if you look at the
solution, of the RG
with that boundary condition,
you see something interesting.
So this is the result
for the coefficient.
One over mu r, minus 1 over a.
So if mu is of order P,
which is much greater than 1
over a, like we want, then
the right counting for the C,
which is a function
of mu, is 1 over M mu.
OK?
And so what we've
done here is we've
swapped 1 over the physics
scale that we're integrating out
for 1 over the scale
mu, which we're
taking to be of order the
physics we're keeping.
OK?
And this is relevant now.
This is a relevant
coupling with that change.
We've made it much
bigger by just
switching to the physical
renormalization scheme.
And if we take mu of
order p in that scheme,
this all of a sudden
becomes an order 1 effect
with leading order
in the Lagrangian,
because we have effectively
P's downstairs in the coupling.
OK?
So this scheme allows
us a way of thinking
in the effective
theory way of thinking
of having a power
counting where we'd have
to keep the C0 to all orders.
AUDIENCE: I thought
it was order--
AP was order 1.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, AP is order 1.
So if you look at
the Lagrangian,
then you have to go through
the counting of how many powers
of P the nucleon field has.
Which you could do in the same
way that we did with the mass.
And if you do that with
the four-nucleon operator
with an extra power
of P downstairs,
you will find it has the same
P scaling as the kinetic term.
OK?
I didn't go through that, but--
AUDIENCE: So that justifies
this, even when P is not
much bigger than 1 over a?
Is that what you're saying?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so if P is
much bigger than 1 over a, or P
is even order or 1 over a,
which is a sort of also--
it's also fine
with this counting.
If P is of order 1
over a, these two terms
are sort of comparably
big, but you could also
use this approach for
that case, as long
as you're not in the case where
P is much less than 1 over a.
So if you're in
that case, then you
should really think about
expanding this out some sense.
And then you're getting back
to the end MS bar result,
the MS bar result
would have been fine.
But to get away from
the MS bar result,
and think about
physics, mu of order P,
we could use this scheme
instead of MS bar,
and then we actually see that
we get a reasonable power
counting.
AUDIENCE: OK, Because my concern
is, what about when mu is like,
what about this pole
that you're going to--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we'll
talk about the pole, yeah.
It's coming up.
All right.
So it's interesting
to think about this
from our renormalization
group point of view, which
is kind of what I was
doing when I wrote down
a beta function that I was--
here I was just
after this solution,
because from that solution I got
the power counting that I want.
Which is that the C0 term is the
same size as the kinetic term,
and both are relevant.
So we can do that just like
we counted P's for [INAUDIBLE]
theory, or just
like we counted--
[? just comment. ?] These
guys are all relevant
as long as we count this mu as
1 over P. 1 over mu is 1 over P.
So there's another way
of thinking about this,
and thinking about
these different cases,
and that's just to think about
the beta function itself.
So if you look at the beta
function for the C0 coupling,
and we just put in the
solution, plug this back
into that equation here,
with some constant out front,
and then it looks like this.
8 times mu, 1 minus
a mu, squared.
If we want to talk about
all possible values of a,
well a can go from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
So it's useful if we want
to draw this to map it
to a compact interval.
So let's do that.
Move the tangent.
And let's just plot
beta as a function of x.
So there's three values,
actually where beta vanishes.
There's one value
where it blows up.
So this is-- here
is x equals minus 1.
This is x equals 0,
this is x equals plus 1.
And what it looks like dips
down here, goes there, blows up,
then it comes back
down, it goes like that.
So that's what the beta
function looks like.
So this point here
corresponds if you
think of being at fixed mu.
Say you're studying the
physics at fixed mu.
This point corresponds to
a equals minus infinity,
this point corresponds
to a equals zero,
and this point corresponds
to a equals plus infinity.
So there's three points where
the beta function vanishes,
if you think about a
space for fixed mu.
Use some color.
So you can ask about nature.
So nature told us the
value of a, so what
does that correspond to?
So taking some value
of P and mapping it
to some value of x, kind of
generically the kind of point
that you're
interested in is here.
This is a1S0, sits there.
And then a for the 3S1
makes it kind of here.
So what's going on in this
case is that you're not
near this fixed point, you're
actually close to this one.
And you're not near
this fixed point,
well actually there's
an infinity in between,
you're closer to this one.
This size you should think
of as 8 MeV, generically,
and then this is like the 8 but
there's also a pole in between.
So three fixed points.
When we do perturbation
theory and we
expand about fixed
points, and one way
of saying what was wrong with
dimensional analysis was it
was just expanding about
the wrong fixed point.
The pink one.
So a equals zero, was
the non-interactive one
where we just had the
relevant interaction
being the kinetic term, but
none of the interaction terms
are relevant.
And a equals plus
or minus infinity
are interacting
fixed points, where
you have an interaction
that is relevant.
So you can think about that
in the following sense.
Classically, what a is measuring
is kind of the interaction
size, if you have classical
scattering across sections
4 pi a squared.
And if a is small--
if a is either very
small or very big,
then basically it's
the same on all scales
because it's either
infinity or 0
and it looks the
same to particles
of all different momenta.
OK?
And that's one way of thinking
about these fixed points.
That the physics can't--
the physics-- yeah.
Just what I said.
So what about this infinity?
That's also interesting.
So when a is one over mu,
beta goes to infinity.
And this actually--
there is a reflection
of this in the theory, it
corresponds to a bound state.
Which I think we'll talk
about next time, but.
So there's a bound
state in the theory,
and actually if you
start from this side,
you can never see that
bound because you're
doing perturbation theory.
You don't see perturbation
theory and bound states.
If you start from this
side, the bound state
is actually just in the theory.
We'll talk about that next time.
And so it's a state in
the theory, you can go
and you could find the
pole in your amplitude,
it's just there.
Corresponds to a physical
state of the spectrum,
and it's called the deuteron.
So we have a
non-interactive theory,
we have some
non-trivial amplitude,
and this deuteron is a
pole in that amplitude.
And you never see a pole if you
use the perturbation theory.
And if you actually look at
the energy, the binding energy
of this state, it's also small.
Characteristically
small, and it's
actually related to the fact
that the binding energy is
small just related to sort of
the natural size of this a.
We'll talk about that next time.
So what I was saying before
about the theory at all scales
looking the same, when you
have a equals 0 of course
it's not interacting.
Or when a is equal to
plus minus infinity,
looks the same at all scales.
That means that scale invariant.
So it's a scale
invariant theory when
a is at these fixed points.
And something I
worked on was the fact
that these points are actually
conformal fixed points.
So that-- there's a conformal
symmetry of the theory that
exists at those points, we'll
talk about that a little bit.
There's another symmetry,
too, which I have to mention.
And not only because I
also worked on this one,
because it's good to
enumerate all the symmetries.
There's actually a combined
spin, isospin symmetry,
that turns into an
Su4 in this limit.
So much like in heavy
quark effective theory
where the mass was big,
new symmetries popped up.
Same thing happens here, when
the scattering lengths go
to infinity, and you go
over to those fixed points,
there's new symmetries
that pop up.
One's a conformal symmetry
and the other one's
a spin, isospin symmetry.
All right.
So this looks interesting.
You could ask the
question, did this pick--
did this physical
picture that we developed
depend on picking
this renormalization
scheme that I told you about?
We kind of gave up on dimreg,
we went over to-- well,
we gave up on MS
bar, we went over
to this scheme which was
offshell momentum subtraction.
In general, people don't like
offshell momentum subtraction
because it makes
calculations more difficult
once you go to higher orders.
Well here, are the calculations
are not so difficult,
so we could do them, but--
you might be interested in
adding pions to this theory,
or coupling external
currents like photons,
and then the calculations
would get more difficult.
And you'd like, for example,
to have a dimreg MS bar type
description of
this power counting
rather than a kind of
minimal subtraction.
Could I get, could
I kind of dress up
minimal subtraction to get
the same physical picture?
That's a reasonable
question to ask.
The answer is you can.
So there's something called
power divergence subtraction
scheme, different
scheme than MS bar.
So the PDS scheme.
And what it says is, don't just
subtract poles at D equals 4,
like you do in MS bar, which
are corresponding to logs
at the cut off, but also
subtract poles and D equals 3.
And dimreg knows about
power law divergences
and they're just poles
at different places
in the dimensions.
And so if we subtract
poles at D equals three,
we can track the power law
divergences in that way.
And it's the power of
divergence that's actually
causing, if you
want to think of it
as a change to the
anomalous dimension, where
the anomalous dimension
was saying this thing
was irrelevant, to changing
it to something relevant,
you need a big change
for that to happen.
And the big change
that's occurring
is coming from a power
law divergence here.
That's what sort of allowed
you to jump, if you like,
from this fixed
point to this one.
The renormalization group,
including the power law
divergence, allows you to even
flow between those points.
Usually we think that power
law divergences aren't
doing anything, here's an
example where they are.
They're not doing
anything as long
as you know you're at
the right fixed point.
If you're describing the
right physics around one
of these fixed points, you
can concentrate on the logs,
but if you don't know where
you are then the power
law divergences
could be crucial.
All right, how does
this scheme work?
So this is a dimreg-type scheme.
So we're going to
get the power of mu
from the mu to the two epsilon
that we have out front.
So if I just write this
guy down in D dimensions,
here's what it looks like.
And I've normalized mu slightly
differently than we usually
do just because it's convenient
for this scheme to do that.
So it's not exactly the same
as MS bar, it's mu over 2
that I'm putting in.
Other than that, it's the
same kind of set up as MS bar.
You'll see why I want to put
that 2 there in a minute.
OK, so this is just the result
that we would write down
for dimensional regularization.
Dimensional regularization
is not a scheme.
A scheme has to do
with what we subtract.
Dimreg is just how we regulate.
So now, look at D equals 4.
So in D equals 4, OK.
There's a bunch of factors.
This is just giving, this is the
answer I quoted to you before.
Something finite.
And if we look at
D equals three,
then we have a pole because
of that gamma function.
And I've put the 2 in here
just to cancel that 2.
And so, what this scheme says
is to add a part subtraction
for this guy.
So what we do is, we
add a counter term.
It looks like minus IM over 4
pi, mu, got one power of mu.
Over 3 minus D. C0 squared.
And then if we take the graph,
plus the counterterm and we
set D equal four, which
is where we actually want
to do physics, lo and behold.
In this approach, you get
actually the same answer
as in our offshell momentum
subtraction scheme.
And that's just really because
this scheme tracks the power
correction, the
power divergence,
just like the offshell
momentum subtraction did.
So we just invented
a dimreg style
of looking for poles that
can track the same physics,
and we just have
to look at poles
in D equals 3 rather than
poles in D equals 4, OK?
And this is easier in general
than the offshell momentum
subtraction scheme, although
for basically everything
we're talking about today
you could do either one.
Now, where is the predictive
power of this effective theory?
So far, we've just kind
of cooked things together
to make the C0 do what we want.
Well, we didn't completely
cook things together.
We switched to another scheme
and it kind of popped out
naturally, but
you can say, well,
why not explore three other
schemes and see if they work?
But let's just imagine that we
got things to work, as we just
did in two different ways
by tracking the power law
divergence.
The predictive power
becomes from now the fact
that if I say that's my fine
tuning, that C0 got enhanced,
I can now predict the size
of all other operators
in the theory.
And other operators
like C2 and C4,
the power counting we assigned
to them previously is not true.
We have to figure it out.
But we can figure
that out once we know
what approach we should use.
OK, so this is same as above.
I won't go through it, but you
know, same anomalous dimension,
et cetera.
And it's easier in general.
Let's think about C2 mu.
So if you look at
C2, the first kind
of diagram you could think about
would be a guy with one C2,
and then this is the
first type of loop diagram
you might think about.
And these guys have a P squared
because C2 gave a P squared.
So they have an extra P squared.
And they diverge.
They also have a
power divergence.
So if you calculate
in either one
of these schemes,
offshell momentum
subtraction, or this PDS scheme,
these guys get a divergence.
And again, it's a
power law divergence
so there's a mu here.
And you get a beta
function, that's that.
2C0 C2.
So if you take the
boundary condition
C2 of 0 which is our MS
bar result. 4 pi over M. A
squared, r0.
And you solve this, you find
C2 of mu is 4 pi over M. 1
over mu minus 1 over a, squared.
r0 over 2.
So there's two-- we
previously, with our counting,
when we were
counting dimensions,
we would have said C0
goes like 1 over lambda,
C2 goes like one
over lambda cubed.
We had 2M plus 1 lambdas.
What we've just
discovered is that yes,
there's a lambda from this
r0, that's a 1 over lambda,
but the other two
lambdas are really mu's.
So this operator
is also enhanced,
and it's enhanced by two powers.
So once you know
leading order theory,
you should be able to determine
the power counting of all
of the other
operators, especially
if they're not relevant ones.
You have to get the
relevant part right,
and then you can
use that Lagrangian
to predict all the scaling
for everything else.
And that's what we've just done.
Gone to 1 over mu
squared lambda.
OK?
And those powers of mu
we see in the scheme,
and the 1 over lambda
comes from the r0.
OK.
So what the RGE actually
does is it tells us--
one way of thinking about
it is that it tells us
the enhancement,
due to fine tuning,
of all operators in the theory.
And that's really because
the fine tuning was just
a change of our power
counting, and we
have to propagate that
change everywhere.
And we can do that, and
it's the beta functions
that tell us how to
propagate the fine tuning.
So if you keep going,
you can do C2K of mu.
You find an anomalous dimension.
This theory is kind of
nice, you can basically
do all the calculations, so.
When you go to CK,
you get contributions
from various lower
order coefficients,
and it's one loop exact
so you only have pairs.
And then you can
kind of contrast
what's going on in a
naive power counting where
P is much less than 1 over a.
Let's just go up to C4.
Versus this kind
of improved power
counting, which is valid when
PA is greater than our order 1.
So C0 hat it went like 1 over
mu, no suppression there.
C2 hat goes like one
over mu squared lambda,
and that actually is irrelevant.
But it's just
irrelevant by one power.
So relative to this guy,
it's down by a P over lambda.
And then interesting
things start
to happen with the
higher ones, at least
from an RGE perspective.
So these guys start to
get more than one term.
But this guy actually doesn't
introduce a new constant.
There's a piece of the anomalous
dimension of this guy that's
actually just fixed
by the constant
that you already had here,
and then there's a new piece.
So the new piece is down
by two powers of lambda.
And that's encoding things about
the amplitude, actually, but--
OK, so that's just
a little table
to kind of convince
you that once you
have a beta function
that you can compute
for the coefficients,
you can quickly
propagate this enhancement
from the fine tuning
to the rest of your theory.
I.e., figure out what
the power counting
is for all the operators.
AUDIENCE: So every time there
is a power law divergence,
should I be worried
if I'm using MS bar,
should I be worried that the
power counting could be wrong?
PROFESSOR: Every time--
Yeah, every time there's
a power law divergence,
it's worth thinking
about whether it
had some physical impact on
what you're doing, I think.
If you know you're expanding--
if you can convince yourself
that you're expanding around
the right fixed point then
you're OK.
That's my equivalence claim.
But you don't
necessarily know that.
So let's go back
to our amplitude
and see what's going
on here, and see
what it looks like with
this power counting.
And so it's really just
a different expansion
of that amplitude that we had.
And in either the PDS scheme or
the power diversion subtraction
scheme, we end up with this
amplitude in the case where
we would use that scheme.
So you can see in PDS that if
I set this coefficient to 0,
the denominator
becomes 1, and then I
get with the offshell
momentum subtraction scheme.
In PDS is a little harder
see that it gives just that,
but it actually gives the
same thing in either scheme.
And if you think about what type
of expansion you're doing here,
you're keeping C0 to all orders.
So your amplitude at
lowest order is just this,
and then the C2 term
looks like that.
And then there's
some higher terms
which I wrote in my notes,
but I want right here.
And what this is, this here
is some kind of interaction.
I'll make it a
bigger circle, which
sums up all the bubbles
with C0's in them.
That's what's happened here.
And this here, if you like,
is like taking C2 and then
dressing it with
bubbles on either side.
So there's two, there's bubbles.
The bubbles on the other side.
And then bubbles on both sides.
So we calculate
these loop graphs
and these are the
amplitudes we get,
and that's because
we're treating
the C0 coupling to all
orders, we're summing it up.
And actually, each of these
amplitudes, if you look
at the RGE, is mu independent.
Explicitly mu independent.
So it's like
perturbation theory,
where we're doing a
momentum expansion,
and order by order in
that momentum expansion,
the amplitude is
independent of the scale mu.
The only purpose
of the scale mu is
to help us think about power
counting of these operators.
In the end of the day, when
we make physical predictions,
then getting mu
independent answers.
OK.
And this is like
organizing, if you like.
And you put it in terms of--
put it back in
terms of a, this is
like organizing the
theory in this way,
where you keep all powers of
AP, and that makes it very clear
that it's mu independent.
Now, this part of
the theory is so
simple you could have
figured that out just
by writing the top line down in
terms of a's and P's and just
writing this line down.
But you could also use what
I've been talking about
to figure out, for example, say
I coupled an external photon
to my four nucleon operators.
How big is this?
OK.
Well, it actually gets enhanced
from the fact the scattering
length is large, and
you can figure out
how important this effect
is, and when people do things
like deuteron formation in
the sun and stuff like that,
they use this effective theory
to do higher order calculations
and make precision predictions
for deuteron physics.
So it's not just a toy model.
It's actually something that has
a real impact on some physics.
We'll talk a little bit
more about it next time.
about the conformal symmetry
and I'll talk a little bit
more about the deuterons
since that's something
interesting in this theory,
and then we'll go on from there.
So, any questions?
It's cool stuff.
Simple to do calculations.
It's kind of interesting
to think about.